le sport maintenant un dimanche
ordinaire sur un circuit de formule 1 à
monaco premier sénat deuxième prost
lionel chamoulaud le triomphe de magic
senna
le brésilien dominateurs de bout en bout
de ce grand prix de monaco
senna avait réalisé la pole position il
s'élance donc en tête
dans le premier tiers de la course alain
prost et dans les roues de son équipier
et rival sans toutefois parvenir à le
dépasser
les dépassements c'est la spécialité de
senna le brésilien va lâcher prost on se
montrant plus habiles dans ce genre
d'exercice
de plus le français sera bloquée par
l'accrochage entre nelson piquet en
jaune et andrea de cesaris en rouge
l'italien
fou de rage
j'étais bloquée complètement à l'arrêt
dans un virage avec l'accrochage de
piquer d'âgés perdu 30 secondes donc
après je me suis baladée j'ai assuré la
deuxième place était une des courses est
plus ennuyeux ce que j'ai fait en tout
cas la seconde partie j'avais pas grand
chose à faire avec 35 secondes de retard
sur ayrton un moment où il n'y avait
donc rien à faire pour battre le buzz ya
aujourd'hui qui remporte ce seizième
victoire prost et senna sont à égalité
de points en tête du championnat du
monde